[Musique]
je ne vais pas me présenter parce que
derrière moi vous allez voir une
présentation bien plus précise de tout
ce que j'aurais pu faire c'est ma carte
d'identité génétique c'est-à-dire
chromosome par promozone les endroits du
monde d'où je viens
voilà je peux préciser aussi que j'ai
2,6 pour cent la dn de néandertal et
avant que vous en déduisez en effet
qu'il ya dans mon physique quelque chose
qui est vraiment mener envers sa lien je
précise que la moyenne européenne ses
2,8
1 voilà si je vous présente ça c'est
pour vous montrer la nature
exponentielle plus progrès
technologiques en 1990 quand les
chercheurs ont lancé un vaste programme
mondial de décryptage de l'adn humain
on pensait à l'époque contenu contenu je
dire de de la puissance des ordinateurs
compte tenu des techniques de séquençage
qui faussent donnant 3 est ce un siècle
pour arriver à décrypter complètement
donc un adn humain
en fait c'était ferme 2003 aujourd'hui
pour avoir un séquençage de cipla il
faut moins d'une heure alors si je vous
parle de ça alors je suis maudit ou par
l'éducation c'est pour vous situer
finalement les problèmes auxquels
l'éducation aujourd'hui à faire face il
ya 3 3 grands problèmes et on va dire un
il ya d'abord évidemment la révolution
technologique
il ya l'impact de la révolution
technologique sur les générations jay z
c'est à dire ceux qui sont nés en 95 et
les suivants et puis l espèce d'angoissé
place planétaire qui qui aujourd'hui
domine véritablement alors deux trois
petits détails là dessus la révolution
technologique il est évident que la
convergence des ntic nanotechnologies
biotechnologies informatique politique
est en train de construire 21e siècle
l'hybride res l'hybridation entre le
numérique la robotique l'intelligence
artificielle est en train va
certainement bouleverser le
fonctionnement nos sociétés
traditionnelles on voit les géants du
numérique américain
les gaffes à mais aussi les géants
chinois un bébé à thé xx dépenses déjà
des sommes considérables attire les
meilleurs cerveaux booth leur
intelligence artificielle à partir des
données que nous nous leur fournissons
un milliard de milliards donnés en
moyenne chaque semaine ils rendent ces
intelligences artificielles de plus en
plus irremplaçable on évolue très
certainement vers une intelligence
artificielle forte
ça veut dire consciente connu qu ayant
ayant finalement l'intelligence d'un
être humain voire l'intelligence d'un de
l'intégralité des êtres humains aux
alentours de 2000 45 ce qui n'est pas
sans poser problème
beaucoup s'en inquiètent déjà la grande
spécialiste japonaise de l'éducation de
l'intelligence artificielle
noriko aaraj dans un teddy kz2 dans un
ted
à tokyo il ya au mois d'août a réussi à
faire passer longue à son programme
d'intelligence informatique s'appelle to
die le concours très sélectifs pour
l'entrée à l'université de tokyo
son programme a réussi à voir mû gauche
en termes de résultats que 80 % des
étudiants qui sont présentés sur des
caractéristiques compenser purement
humaine faire une dissertation répondre
un oral donc ça l'à beaucoup inquiété et
elle appelle à une réflexion rapide je
dire sur la manière dont on va
coexistaient que l'intelligence
artificielle et lone musk qui vous
connaissez un travers space x la tesla
lui aussi s'inquiète
il vient de créer donc une société
américaine qui s'appelle me ralink avec
l'objectif d'en cinq ans finalement nous
poser des implants cérébraux pour
résister à l'intelligence artificielle
des somme de clés usb qu'on rajouterait
à nos cerveaux alors ces grandes
questions je veux dire même si tous les
théoriciens sont pas sur la même ligne
ces grandes questions finalement
l'intelligence artificielle
l'augmentation du cerveau la capacité à
dépasser la sélection darwinienne voire
même l'immortalité et à mon âge
on commence à s'y intéresser vraiment
sont évidemment des grands les grands
enjeux du 21e siècle le cerveau
biologique et la bataille du 21e siècle
donc le premier point l'école par
rapport à ça quelle est la place de
l'école par rapport à ça qu'elle est
même son devenir le deuxième point après
le deuxième grosse difficulté de l'école
c'est qu'évidemment cette révolution
technologique
elle n'est pas sans impact sur la
génération elle les enfants qui sont nés
à partir de 95 et les suivants il ya eu
un colloque à l'académie des sciences
qui avait eu lieu en 2014 et les
aqueducs au l'autre du colloque tu
montres en fait qu'on est sur quatre
évolutions alors je vais y arriver un
prêt là les quatre évolutions donc c'est
la révolution de la relation aux savoirs
de la relation apprentissage de la
relation aux autres et aussi du
fonctionnement psychique
d'accord c'est pas sans conséquence non
plus sur des choses très important le on
a on assiste à l'heure actuelle et les
études le prouvent à une sorte de
réorganisation cérébrale pour les
adolescents c'est pas les mêmes schémas
neuronaux qui sont employés et c'est
tellement déjà ancrée je n'ai pas les
grandes entreprises par exemple que même
des entreprises tout proche de bordeaux
comme thalès ou d'assaut font pas le
même type de recrutement en fonction de
l'âge et mettent pas forcément les gens
qui sont recrutés dans les mêmes salles
d'accord le deuxième point aussi qui est
important c'est le langage depuis la
création de l'académie française en 1635
et un nouveau dictionnaire tous les 30
ans et ce dictionnaire en moyenne ya
quatre à cinq mille mots qui bougent
d'un indic d'un dictionnaire à l'autre
la dune comme l'expliquent me philosophe
michel serres on va avoir dans la
version su qui arrivent là on va avoir
30 mille mots qui bouge quand on sait
qu'un étudiant qui a une vingtaine
d'années donc
on utilise en moyenne 60 mille mots on
connait soixante mille mots combien de
générations faudra-t-il pour qu'on parle
un français qui leur apparaîtra
incompréhensible comme nous suit de
christiane 3 juin vie yvo de boer neu
les médiévaux aujourd'hui ou far et
étrangères d'accord voilà ça c'est le
deuxième rang de soucis quelle place
pour l'école par rapport à st et puis le
troisième souci et qui est un souci qui
est qui et qui est récent c'est le souci
d'un angoisse planétaire on est tous
maintenant conscients de notre
communauté de destin
les mêmes peurs écologique les mêmes
peurs économique les mêmes dangers face
au nucléaire
merci encore à donald et kim de nous les
avoir réactivé les mêmes dangers par
rapport au fanatisme religieux et c'est
ça finalement c'est très récent - glg en
arrière grand oncle si au début du 20e
siècle
si j'arrive à le montrer voilà qui au
début du 20e siècle pouvait partir dans
les îles du pacifique comme missionnaire
rencontrés n'étaient des tribus
anthropophage qui n'avait pas connu
l'homme encore ils pouvaient aussi au
nom de la france 30 procession de
prendre possession d'une île la plus
grande île du pacifique lille qui rit
tim matthys et donner des noms de ma
famille à tous les coins de cette île
des noms qui existe encore aujourd'hui
ça aujourd'hui c'est fini on est
vraiment sur la prise de conscience de
notre terre patrie comme dirait de
guerre morin on est sur la prise de
conscience face de deux d'un destin
commun alors ce qui est incroyable on
alors qu'on pensait que ça pouvait soudé
solidariser l'humanité ce qu'on voit un
peu partout c'est en recroquevillement
cd régression vers des identités c'est
une peur de l'étranger multiples c'est
la progression des régimes autoritaires
et tout ça ça fait une source d'angoissé
planétaire et quand on sait que
l'éducation c'est au ciné c'est aussi le
début de
l'éducation est vraiment de donner envie
de rentrer dans un monde dans le monde
convient comment aujourd'hui donner
envie je veux dire à des adolescents de
rentrer dans un monde alors tous les
adultes véhicule cette forme d'angoissé
finalement ça c'est les 3 grands c'est
les trois grands problèmes de l'école
alors par rapport à ça ce que l'école
est adapté est-ce que l'école qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui est adapté
évidemment non aller à l'école jeudi on
a l'impression que c'est une chose qui
est complètement naturel or tous les
systèmes scolaires de masse sont nés au
xixème siècle et ils sont un peu ce ils
sont un petit peu de la même manière en
accompagnant donc en accompagnant un
petit peu le la montée industrielle il
ya plusieurs caractéristiques assez
système scolaire la première chose
évidemment c'est que c'est un modèle
éducatif industrielle on dirait
tayloriste fournissent tu organisation
origines organisation rigide eux ont
fait des maths en malt ont fait du
français en français sonnerie en début
de cours et enfin de cours empilement
des heures comme des tranche napolitaine
qui parmi vous est capable de suite fois
une heure d'accord on verrait déjà la
fin d'après midi c'est compliqué donc
huit fois une heure et on en deçà des
ados donc ça sert et premier regard et
c'est ici que la deuxième
caractéristique c'est l'hiérarchie
nation d intelligence on privilégie
l'intelligence au détriment des autres
et à l'époque des travaux de howard
gardner et des intelligences multiples
il y as par rapport à ça quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne plus
troisième point si on est sur des
programmes et des d'évaluation
standardisée un peu partout dans le
monde c'est le même fonctionnement
c'est-à-dire on a cessé
on a une hiérarchie subtil des matières
par tous un petit peu les maths en
premier suivi la langue du pays suivi
des autres sciences sciences humaines et
puis au fond du panier on allait on a
toutes les matières artistiques et le ps
bien entendu si accompagné aussi de
choix il ya des grands oublie par
exemple sur la place des femmes qui
parmi vous qu'on est à spa s'il milliers
que socrate considéré comme son égal et
avec qui il discutait 3 et souvent et
qui est devenu après la compagne de
périclès le grand réformateur qui
le grand réformateur athéniens qui parmi
vous conte aimant samoussas que le
magazine forbes vient de classer parmi
les cinq ans l'empereur du mali au 14e
siècle viennent classé parmi les cinq
hommes les plus riches qui ait jamais
existé sur terre
voilà on est sur des oublis comme ça
qu'ils sont qui sont vraiment importants
et puis ces programmes ils font toujours
débat
ils sont sans cesse en querelles en 1902
par exemple la place du latin dans
l'enseignement en frace en l'ap la place
prééminente est remise en cause pendant
20 ans une lutte mais qui est une lutte
absolument terrible la lutte entre
républicains pédago aujourd'hui fait
presque allures de fait presque allure
je dire de de lutte de cour de
récréation par rapport à la violence des
écrits d'époque et ça continue à faire
débat
comme vous l'avez peut-être vu en 2017
la finlande qui est un des deux ou trois
pays les mieux notés par d'abandonner
les matières scolaires pour les
remplacer par une étude par sujet pisa
le kiki qui est pisa donc les études
pisa viennent d'ajouter en 2015 la
résolution de problèmes collaboratif
dans les danses qu'ils évaluent d'accord
donc un peu partout dans le monde on
voit bien que ce système à la fois il
est à bout de souffle
on voit bien qu'il faut le réformer on
essaye de le réformer un peu partout
mais ça c'est pas suffisant la
désynchronisation entre l'école et le
monde qui lui galloppa toute allure et l
comment donner c'est des révolutions cas
arriver je crois qu'on peut lister deux
révolutions qui vont certainement
fonctionner comme un tsunami
la première révolution c'est ça va être
la remise en cause des métiers auxquels
l'école prépare et qui vont être
remplacés sa demande par des métiers
auteur complexe non sérotypes et est
donc on n'est pas forcément encore
bétonneurs la deuxième révolution ça va
être que le le le très rapidement vont
être rendues obsolètes les technologies
transmission qui existe aujourd'hui dans
tous les systèmes éducatifs
on en voit les prémices de ça on voit
les prémisses déjà on voit déjà
l'internât l'internationalisation des
formations on voit l'individualisation
des parcours
on voit aussi le début d'un
marchandisation de l'éducation
je vais prendre un exemple les moque les
manques en 2012 mon premier mode donc à
l'université de standford sur
l'intelligence artificielle par
sebastian tron qui travaillait aussi à
google et depuis on a on a quelque chose
qui est absolument exponentielle de tous
les côtés ça progresse je vous donne un
exemple vous naissez déjà certainement
tout celui de la khan academy en 2010 à
être la khan academy c'est 7 7 millions
2,7 millions d'étudiants du collège à
l'université
chaque mois douze fois ce que harvard à
a scolarisé depuis son ouverture en 1630
et avec la capacité incroyable de
pouvoir repérer les erreurs plusieurs
années avant à faire un suivi
individualisé
on voit aussi avec quelque chose qui est
en train de se développer beaucoup
si j'arrive cdd courts comme le hbx
d'harward c'est à dire la capacité donc
qu'on maintenant et les dons les grandes
écoles a créé les salles de classe
virtuelle avec des sessions en temps
réel ou des étudiants du monde entier se
connecte on a la foi l'interactivité la
sensation d'intimité on peut travailler
donc sur des diagnostics cognitif sur la
reconnaissance sociale sur l'analyse des
émotions
on est en train de passer sur autre
chose on est vraiment en train de passer
sur autre chose
le l'intelligence artificielle et le big
data aujourd'hui font composent suivent
des milliers d'étudiants en même temps
ce qu'on peut pister lors que leur
capacité de progression et sa bouche
totalement les lignes on peut à la fois
faire des remédiations sur des nombres
et non on peut aussi donner des pistes
de progression
travailler sur les apprentissages
cognitif alors néanmoins je dire on en
est encore pour ceux qui connaissent un
peu léger vidéo on a encore presque au
jeu de ping pong d'accord sur les jeux
vidéo et on en est très très loin du
world of warcraft
je vous fait profiter de mon bon anglais
scolaire français à mi chemin entre
maurice chevalier sans canotiers et
nicolas sarkozy
voilà donc on est on est on est un petit
peu sur sa donc ce que je crois pour
revenir au terme au terme donc de la
conférence deux choses c'est que je
crois que il faut bouger pour que le
système éducatif survivre il faut bouger
deux choses d'abord la formation des
profs des profs que rassurer la
massification il faut les laisser finir
mais à part ça je dire il faut
fondamentalement changé
la formation des profs certes mieux
payés plus présent mais avec des
formations beaucoup plus pointu et qui
corresponde ont certainement à la
définition qu'on en attendant le futur
et puis le deuxième point ce qu'il faut
c'est mettre en avance c'est mettre en
avant ses compétences
trois blocs de neuf compétences être
neuf
oui trois blocs de trois compétences qui
aujourd'hui sont pas forcément mis en
valeur j'allais dire la créativité la
capacité à innover
la curiosité j'ai pas forcément
m'étendre là dessus c'est tellement
évident je dire un mais c'est tout de
même des notions qui à l'heure actuelle
sont pas mises en avant par le système
néanmoins l'expression artistique la
10ème la dissémination
la désintermédiation le l'engagement des
élèves dans la construction du savoir
l'expression artistique la ludification
on pourra pas en faire l'économie
c'est tellement important 2e 2e grand
triptyque c'est le sait ce qu'on a c'est
ce que j'appelais l'esprit critique le
civisme et la communication
je crois que l'esprit critique avec le
numérique là aussi c'est pas besoin de
m'étendre c'est évident qu'avec le
numérique il faut il faut développer
l'esprit critique
le philosophe paul ricoeur le philosophe
paul ricoeur disait que la démocratie
l'inter argumentation rationnelle et je
crois que c'est ça c'est à dire arriver
à poser sa parole
accepter la parole de l'autre arrivé à
réfléchir sereinement par rapport à ça
c'est vraiment très important
la formation un citoyenneté et là je
prends les propos d'un pédagogue
s'appelle jaunes d'oeufs ouais il dit
finalement la démocratie serait invente
à chaque génération et c'est l'éducation
qui en l accoucheur d'accord
et c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
important après il ya la communication
vous entendez beaucoup dans les médias à
l'heure actuelle lire écrire compter
certes il la france et le pays de l'osce
et des oeufs qui consacrent le plus de
temps par rapport à ce qu'on pouvait
entendre mais c'est pas que ça on a
absolument besoin aujourd'hui et vous le
sentez un jeu dire de de l'oral de
l'oral tout simplement pour s'insérer
dans la vie professionnelle
et puis moi j'aurais volontiers ajouter
autre chose de l'oral aussi parce que
comme le dit lacan la violence et la
parole d'un abouti dont il faut vraiment
travailler là dessus et je crois que
c'est très important voilà dernier
triptyque la coopération l'empathie et
la bienveillance la coopération ça paris
tout même incroyable que le système
scolaire sans sopap emparer même les
travaux collectifs sont même les travaux
collectifs sont notés individuellement
aujourd'hui dans système et on voit face
à des systèmes qui sont plus en plus
complexe que la paix la coopération est
une évidence beaucoup d'entre vous
connaissent peut-être l'expérience de
foldit
c'est à dire pendant dix ans les
chercheurs en bloquer sur la recherche
d'une structure tridimensionnelle d'une
protéine rétroviral je l'appris parker
ça parce que je suis pas guère plus
pétillant de ça et il n'y arrivait pas
donc il a suffi qu'il met sur le site
foldit est en trois semaines grâce aux
internautes du monde qui ont travaillé
qui sont renvoyés des choses le problème
était résolu et on a franchi un cap
important finalement de bain dans la
lutte contre contre le sida
d'accord l'empathie donc j'y reviendrai
pas dessus et je vais tergnier pas
bienveillance alors je vois déjà joie
des chantres à dire bien gentil de
monsieur mais compte tenu du contexte
mondial la bienveillance d'accord moi ce
que je voulais simplement vous dire mais
parmi les trois grandes bornes
littéraire et à primo levi qui a connu
les camps de concentration nazis
il ya vassili grossman ya varlam
chalamov qui ont eux ont connu les camps
de concentration soviétiques qui ont
connu le pire du pire de ce qu'un humain
peut connaître et ils en sortent tous
sortis en finalement on parle en deçà en
dix ans
10 ans ce qui est important delà des
idéologies au delà de la religion c'est
cette capacité de l'être humain
finalement à faire des petits sacs de
bonté d'un individu à un autre
voilà et ceux qui croient que c'est sale
ça la base de l'humanité vers lequel on
doit année je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]